er Is there a finals? The live showdown is a
good match with a lot of people on the other side than on the other side
.
ー yeah
[Applause]
Epyon bread
tuhan It's
not like that, so it's going to be good
[music]
We're selling
someone who doesn't slow down at all
Halfway through that, it's hard to be a gluttony champion The
reason why I'm going to authenticate the prince fire Jump
to [music]  I'm selling it
[music] I
've got rid of the worms, and I'm sure that's the condolence guy
[music
] What's up with the
extra refills?
]
Onbahn No
matter how delicious it is, no matter how hot
it is, it's no big deal Emphasis: We weren't supposed to eat delicious food together
.
I'm
sorry for the store par
ran It
was a little useful I
'll be able to say it
2nd place
[music]
boo boo goo